aterrizaje confirmado pero servirán a
salvo en la superficie de marte listo
para empezar a buscar signos de vida
pasada
un estallido de alegría al final de un
viaje espacial de siete meses y al
inicio de una nueva misión para explorar
el planeta rojo el vehículo de
exploración de la nasa llegó a suelo
marciano el jueves después de varias
complicadas maniobras tuvo que
desacelerar desde los 20 mil kilómetros
por hora hasta los 0 fueron siete
minutos de terror según el control de la
misión
[Aplausos]
en general todo fue según el plan y
cuando escuché la señal del aterrizaje y
vi la primera imagen no puedo explicar
las emociones que me abruman
la primera imagen transmitida desde
marte por el perseverance es una
polvorienta foto en blanco y negro ahora
empieza su verdadero trabajo el rover
con seis ruedas y del tamaño de un coche
es el laboratorio de biología más
avanzado que se ha enviado a otro
planeta su principal misión es explorar
el cráter yeshiva donde antes había el
delta de un río para buscar pruebas de
vida microscópica de hace millones de
años cuando el planeta era más cálido y
todavía corría el agua
para hacerlo usará un brazo de dos
metros para perforar la superficie y
recolectar docenas de muestras que
encerrará en tubos para que otro robot
los recupere la nasa espera trasladar
las muestras a la tierra en 2031
el rover también tiene otras misiones
como probar un helicóptero miniatura
para investigar en alturas bajas y
probar un equipo para convertir co2 en
oxígeno ambos inventos podrían abrir un
camino a la exploración humana de marte